ich begrüße sie zu erneut einer
pressekonferenz zur coroner lage und
größe dazu rechts neben mir den
gesundheitsminister professor dr karl
lauterbach da neben dem präsidenten des
robert koch instituts professor dr
lothar wieler und heute ebenfalls zu
gast die chefärztin der median klinik in
heiligendamm die uns etwas zu krone und
long beach
berichten kann dr jördis frommhold
herzlich willkommen ihnen drei alle drei
werden zu beginn etwas sagen bevor wir
wie gewohnt zu ihren fragen kommen und
damit hat als erster der minister das
wort ja vielen dank frau buch ich darf
mich zunächst für die möglichkeit hier
liebe presse zu informieren ganz
herzlich bedanken
ich fange einmal an mit der situation
die wir derzeit beobachten bei der
entwicklung der fallzahlen
und auch bei der hospitalisierung
gesamtlage es kann uns nicht
zufriedenstellen
ja sind an der situation die ich als
kritisch bezeichnen und möchte wir haben
stark steigende fallzahlen wieder die
super nanny die mit der omicron variante
hat sich verschoben dass der anteil der
baa2 sub variante immer mehr bedeutung
gewinnt das ist nicht nur ein problem
steigender incidents sondern das ist
auch ein problem für die krankenhaus
belastung mittelfristig und es ist jetzt
schon ein problem für die menschen die
an kurve zu versterben ich lese immer
wieder die omikron variante sei eine
mildere variante das stimmt nur begrenzt
und wir haben also eine variante hier
mann der zwischen 200 und 250 menschen
pro tag derzeit sterben die scherbe zahl
kann weiter steigen
vergessen sind 249 menschen gestorben
wir können nicht zufrieden sein mit
einer situation wo 200 bis 250 menschen
jeden tag sterben und die perspektive
die ist also in wenigen wochen mehr
menschen da und versterben war
diejenigen die sich jetzt infizieren
sterben typischerweise erst in einigen
wochen das ist somit ein unhaltbare
situation
auf die wir auch reagieren müssen das
macht mir große sorge die lage ist
objektiv viel schlechter als die
stimmung die stimmung in der bevölkerung
auch in teilen der politischen
landschaft ist so dass wir also die pan
mich schon bewältigt hätten es ist auch
darüber nachgedacht worden ob also man
da offiziell tage
betrachtet als tage der freiheit oder
also
sich anders also auf diese situation
einlässt mit dem gedanken das ist hinter
uns dem liegt einfach die
fehleinschätzung zugrunde da ist die
omikron variante niemanden mehr wirklich
tödlich gefährt das ist aber für
ungeimpfte nicht der fall und auch
diejenigen geimpft sind können an der
omicron variante schwer erkranken und
können langfristige symptome entwickeln
na ja danke ich verfolgt die in diesem
bereich besonders ausgewiesen ist dass
uns heute also verstärken wird und über
die lohnkosten
hinweisen dort die situation ist also
nicht gut schon wir müssen da auch
reagieren ich möchte ausdrücklich auf
das infektionsschutzgesetz noch kurz
also zu sprechen kommen und dann etwas
zu allgemein und im pflicht sein beim
infektionsschutzgesetz haben wir uns in
der ampel auf eine formulierungshilfe
durch die regierung geeinigt im
wesentlichen auf der grundlage von
verhandlungen
die justizminister buschmann und ich
geführt haben dass wir also auf zwei
ebenen dem also profit probleme in
zukunft begegnen wollen und zwar
allgemeinen schutzmaßnahmen das sind im
wesentlichen
masken und tests für die wohngruppen und
tests für die schulen und die kitas und
daneben weitergehender maßnahmen
die in sogenannten hot spots dann zum
tragen kommen und dazu zählen dann die
klassischen schutzmaßnahmen die wir alle
kennen also dann wieder masken es kommen
dazu
[Musik]
stans gebote es kommen dazu die üblichen
verfahren fest nachweise die verlangt
werden können impfungen die nachgewiesen
werden müssen genießen status der
nachgewiesen werden muss und als vierte
maßnahme die hygiene stand also die
hygiene konzepte genauso und da ist die
frage ist das ein instrumentarium womit
man wählen beherrschen kann oder ist das
zu wenig hätte man etwas anderes
beschließen müssen zunächst einmal die
fläche wo das zum tragen kommt der
hotspot das ist die konkret zu benennen
der gebietskörperschaft das ist konkret
die region wo der ausbruch gerade ist
ist das in einer stadt ist dass die
stadt ist das in einer region ist dass
die region ist der ausbruch
flächendeckend im ganzen land ist dass
das bundesland somit die
gebietskörperschaft kann auch ein ganzes
bundesland
betreffend die begrifflichkeit des
hotspots ist hier missverständlich für
den ein oder anderen weil der hotspot
ist jetzt nicht eine kleine region in
einem bundesland sondern wenn der
ausbruch das ganze bundesland betritt
dann ist das das bundesland zum zweiten
ist ist also richtig das
ausbruchsgeschehen was den hot spot also
bescheid an die inzidenz und an die
drohende überlastung der krankenhäuser
zu knüpfen das ist ja was wir hier
gemacht haben ja in der zwei kriterien
gemacht dass eine kriterium seine
besonders gefährliche neue variante und
das andere kriterium ist steigende
inzidenz und drohende krankenhaus
überlastung oder hohe incidents und
steigende krankenhaus überlastung sind
das kriterien die man vielleicht nicht
gebraucht hätte hätte man vielleicht
sagen können diese vier massnahmen
hätten ergriffen werden können ohne
rücksicht auf die inzidenz und ohne
rücksicht auf die krankenhaus
überlassung das ist ja eine frage die
man sich stellen muss da ist die
schnelle antwort nein das wäre nicht
möglich gewesen weil wir müssen diese
eingriffe in die freiheit des rasenden
rechtfertigen wir wären mit einer
formulierung dass man unabhängig von der
in stents und unabhängig von der
situation in den krankenhäusern die
maßnahmen ergreifen kann werden wir
selbst vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
nicht durchbekommen und das hätte auch
kein lokales gericht mitgemacht somit
ich werde immer wieder jetzt also darauf
hingewiesen auch von ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidenten wieso hat es
denn nicht so gemacht
wir nutzen diese vier maßnahmen und
jetzt geschickt lass das doch die
landesregierungen machen unabhängig von
der inzidenz und unabhängig von der
krankenhaus belastung das ist ein
frommer gedanke es geht aber schlicht
nicht ich muss es ja begründen können
ich muss ja sagen
weshalb diese maßnahmen ergriffen werden
dürfen das kann ja nicht einfach auf
vorrat beschließen somit gab es dazu
dass an die inzidenz und andy
krankenhaus überlastung zu knüpfen keine
alternative die einzige alternative die
man gehabt hätte man hätte dass man
deswegen nicht den landesparlamenten
überlassen sondern einfach den
regierungen den landesregierungen
und dann tat der kritik der
landesregierungen die doch darauf zurück
dass jetzt die landesparlamente bemüht
werden müssen das ist aber aus meiner
sicht sogar ein fortschritt denn wenn
das von der regierung und vom land
beschlossen wird der hotspot und die
drohende überlastung und die hohe
incident dann ist es auch sicher vor
gericht man muss wenn man etwas
kritisieren auch konkret benennen was
wäre die alternative gewesen
und die alternative diese maßnahmen zu
beschließen und unabhängig von der
inzidenz und unabhängig von der
krankenhaus belastung wäre einfach
schlicht nicht möglich gewesen und die
übertragung dieser aufgabe allein an die
landesregierung hätte die
rechtsunsicherheit
mitgebracht die wir derzeit überall
beklagen ist sind ja zahlreiche dieser
rechtsverordnung das sind eine
rechtsverordnung in der jeweiligen
landesregierung sind ja kassiert worden
stichwort mildenburg und so weiter somit
glaube ich ist es nicht richtig zu sagen
und das sage ich als jemand der also
eine kritische bemerkung immer zu
schätzen was und die auch ein versucht
einzufliegen aber hier ist es einfach
nicht richtig dass man einfach sagt die
hat sich die fdp durchgesetzt sondern in
dieser situation im was diesen punkt
angeht bin ich nicht nur der gleichen
meinung also wir buschmann mit dem
schluss verhandelt habe sondern ganz
offen gesagt es war sogar meinen
vorschlag weil wir müssen das recht
sicher haben und wir müssen das in einer
form haben dass es auch gebunden ist
also an incidents und also an die
depressionen wir werden mit diesem
gesetz sehr schnelle gelage kommen mit
dem neuen infektionsschutzgesetz darfst
die landesparlamente das einsetzen
müssen wir sind ja schon in hotspots und
wir sind in vielen regionen kurzform
ortsrat somit würde ich die
ministerpräsidenten und minister wollen
die landesregierungen und die
landesparlamente auch auffordern sich
nicht mit der kritik am gesetz
aufzuhalten das gesetz funktioniert
sondern die nutzung des gesetzes einfach
vorzubereiten denn wir sind hier wenige
tage quasi wo wir in eine situation
kommen wo die nutzung des gesetzes
notwendig sein wird wir werden dieses
gesetz sehr schnell einsetzen müssen
weil bei der entwicklung der fallzahlen
erwarte ich hotspots in zahlreichen
bundesländern und dann muss das gesetz
umgesetzt werden statt zu kritisieren
was das gesetz nicht bringe muss man das
was das gesetz bringen kann auch sofort
vorbereiten und nutzen kommen zum
abschluss ganz kurz also zur
allgemeinen pflicht die lage in der wir
jetzt sind die als omikron variante
stark sehr stark und wir haben 250 tote
pro tag
zeigt dass wir ohne eine allgemeine
impfpflicht die partie im herbst nicht
in den griff bekommen das wurde einfach
nicht funktioniert wir werden im herbst
vor genau der gleichen situation stehen
wir jetzt wenn nicht schlimmer und ich
hatte christian drosten als
konsiliarlabor für
also die generieren noch einmal gebeten
eine kurze stellungnahme zu erarbeiten
was auch ganze zweiter gemeinsamer
dankenswerterweise gemacht hat in bezug
auf die frage wie geht das denn
genetische zweite welche varianten
müssen wir erwarten ja wir können die
omikron variante erwarten so wie jetzt
dann sind wir im herbst wieder genau da
wo wir jetzt sind was an lange ist wo
wir dann die schließung und mit
anregungen spätestens machen müssen oder
aber die harmonie von variante verändert
sich und wird auch noch pathogene es
gibt viele gründe dass für möglich zu
halten so dass es dann so ansteckend ist
wie omikron aber etwas gefährlicher
die dritte möglichkeit ist die dass wir
einen stamm der data warnte sehen wie
wir jetzt was jetzt in südamerika sehen
dann hätten wir auch noch eine stärkere
sterblich hat und da dann die impfung in
ihrer wirkung schon ein stück weit
zurückgegangen ist für diese variante
hätten wir weniger impfschutz in das
vierte wer eine re kombinierte variante
eine kombination zum beispiel von nikon
und data wie wir es jetzt in england
gesehen haben um über diese fälle schon
sehen und wo wir auch den ersten fall
herr wieder wird ausführen auch in
deutschland haben das werden sie die
vier szenarien aber unter allen
szenarien brauchen wir die endlich ich
werde immer wieder konfrontiert mit dem
argument
promikon ist ja nicht so gefährlich wir
brauchen keine impfpflicht das ist
erstens falsch 250 todesfälle wie jetzt
das ist ja nur der anfang wenn dies
alles öffnen würde wer noch eine ganz
andere belastung zeigt dass omikron
durchweg gefährlich ist und wir können
uns mit der lage nicht abfinden wir
müssen auch jetzt die maßnahmen
ergreifen die wir schon gegessen haben
wir wollen dass der pandemie heraus wir
wollen nicht immer alles zu lassen und
non profit wird vor form und gleich
darauf hinweisen dann daher ist das
argument falsch dann wird darauf
hingewiesen dass die impfungen schützen
ja nicht vor ansteckung erstens ist das
falsch die impfungen nach der booster
impfung schützen ganz gut vor ansteckung
wenn auch nicht perfekt und zum zweiten
sich schützen hat von schwerer krankheit
tödlicher krankheit deshalb müssen wir
denn jetzt
diese schutzmaßnahmen nach fsg nach der
hotspot regelung vorbereitet naja weil
so viele ungeimpft sind und so schwer
erkranken dass sie in die krankenhäuser
müssen oder gar auf die intensivstation
oder gar versterben somit selbst wenn es
so wäre
dass die impfungen vor der eigentlichen
infektion nicht schützen würden was
falsch ist wer der schutz vor der
schweren erkrankung der grund dafür
weshalb wir tatsächlich diese impfungen
brauchen um alle situationen im herbst
zu verhindern die wir jetzt haben und
zum schließen
es ist
auch nicht die impfung gegen die omikron
variante ja aber eben ausgeführt wir
haben ja hier vier möglichkeiten omikron
bleibt omikron wird gefährlicher die
data variante kommt in einer ganz
anderen variante heraus oder wir haben
rekombination darauf bereiten wir uns
vor und die infoman wirken gegen alle
vier möglichkeiten weil über 90 prozent
etwa 96 prozent des genoms
der wären auch die unterschiedlichen
stämme betreffend bionicon ist ein
bisschen anders sind über die varianten
identisch das ist der grund weshalb auch
die alten wo hahn impfstoffe noch immer
so fantastisch wirken gegen die schwere
erkrankung daher wir brauchen die
allgemeine impfpflicht unbedingt die
argumente gegen die allgemeine
impfpflicht sind wissenschaftlich falsch
und wir werden daher in der im deutschen
bundestag eine debatte haben die im
prinzip darüber entscheidet ob wir im
herbst wir uns dann wieder treffen und
diskutieren die gleichen probleme oder
ob wir das abwenden können
danke dafür dann als nächstes jahr
wieder bitte ja die fallzahlen und die
inzidenz 'nen steigen wieder und
weiterhin herrscht ein sehr hoher
infektionsdruck auf die bevölkerung in
vielen landkreisen liegt die inzidenz
immer noch über 2000 teilweise sogar
über 2500 warum sehen wir diesen anstieg
der insolvenzen es wurde eben schon
ausgeführt von minister lauterbach wir
wissen dass der anteil der omicron sub
linie baa2 zunimmt und zwar sowohl
international als auch in deutschland
und zwar kontinuierlich im letzten
wochen bericht lag der anteil bei rund
38 prozent in diesen wochen berichteten
wir gestern publizierte liegt er bei
rund 50 prozent bereits und im haushalt
studien aus dänemark und auch aus
großbritannien die deuten darauf hin
dass br 2 leichter übertragbar ist das
heißt dass es sich noch schneller
ausbreiten als baa1 dazu kommt dass in
einigen bundesländern die
schutzmaßnahmen auch schrittweise
gelockert werden und dadurch verändert
sich natürlich auch das verhalten von
vielen menschen aber lassen uns das
ganze mal ein wenig genauer anschauen
die zahl der hospitalisierten cupid 19
patienten in den letzten wochen ist
gestiegen insbesondere auch natürlich
weil die instanzen in den höheren
altersgruppen gestiegen sind zur zeit
werden immer noch über
2.000 patienten und patientinnen
intensivstation behandelt und diese zahl
die gehen kaum bzw nur ganz langsam
zurück fast die hälfte von diesen auf
intensivstationen ist über 70 jahre alt
in den letzten vier wochen sind auch
schon mehr sind mehr als
4200 menschen im zusammenhang mit der
chor wird 19 infektion verstorben
aktuell werden wieder mehr als 1000
todesfälle pro woche an das rki
übermittelt
und zwar mit einer steigenden tendenz
86 prozent der todesfälle betreffen
menschen die über 70 jahre alt sind das
sind die menschen die einer großen
risikogruppe angehören das ist eine
große gruppe von menschen in unserem
land 14 prozent der verstorbenen aber
sind dann entsprechend unter 70 jahre
alt noch mal dass ein punkt zurück 14
prozent von 2 von 4.200 das sind 588
menschen die unter 70 jahre sind und in
den letzten vier wochen im rahmen von
kogit verstorben sind das heißt also
nach wie vor erkranken viel zu viele
menschen schwer ankurbelt und nach wie
vor sterben auch zu viele menschen an
dieser erkrankung und nach wie vor
erleiden auch viele menschen
langzeitfolgen von kogit und ich bin
sehr froh dass heute vdr frommhold uns
da einblicke geben wird in die situation
von mitmenschen gehe unter diesen
langzeit folgen leiden das sind
erwachsene jugendliche
aber auch kinder können von
langfristigen gesundheitlichen folgen
betroffen sein also von dem so genannten
long cupid jetzt im kenntnisstand ist
ein erheblicher teil der erwachsenen
nach vorangegangener saß koch 2
infektionen von lancôme betroffen kinder
und jugendliche scheinen weniger
betroffen zu sein allerdings ist die
datenlage hier nach wie vor
eingeschränkt ein teil der betroffenen
und das wird glaube ich glaube es
ausgeführt bleibt doch längerfristig
stark eingeschränkt wie viele das sind
und wie genau und wie lange das ist das
wissen wir noch nicht genau aber
schwerer verläufe todesfälle und nach
ersten studien auch longo witt können zu
einem großen teil vermieden werden und
zwar durch die impfung
die lage ist also weiterhin angespannt
aber wir können das infektionsgeschehen
mit unserem verhalten beeinflussen das
wissen wir alle das haben wir gelernt in
den letzten beiden jahren die haben alle
werkzeuge die wir benötigen um
ansteckungen zu verhindern darüber
sollten wir alle bestmöglich weiterhin
nutzen lassen sie uns achtsam sein eine
maske tragen in innenräumen und bei
menschenansammlungen und wann immer es
geht sollten wir diese
menschenansammlungen eigentlich meiden
denken wir auch in unserer mitmenschen
die ein höheres risiko für eine schwere
erkrankung am entscheiden wir uns für
ein verhalten das andere schützt die
wohlhabenden menschen in unserer
gesellschaft sind auf diesen schutz
angewiesen die impfung ist und bleibt
der beste und sicherste weg zur
immunität die bekannten impfreaktionen
sind im vergleich zu den folgen einer
infektion deutlich weniger ausgeprägt
die impfung schützt uns eben nicht nur
vor schweren verläufen und vor dem tod
sondern auch von longo witt dabei
schützt wir eben nicht nur uns selbst
sondern auf alle menschen mit denen wir
in kontakt kommen und damit auch alle
menschen die uns wichtig sind
danke frau dr frommhold bitte
longo wird ist längst kein einzelfall
mehr das sollte jetzt mehr als deutlich
geworden sein es sind mehrere
hunderttausend bis zum teil millionen
menschen bei uns in deutschland die von
diesem krankheitsbild betroffen sind und
das sind nicht wie häufig angenommen die
alten die kranken oder die menschen die
eine ungesunde lebensweise führen
sondern sind die jungen die sportlichen
und die dynamischen menschen die das
ganze leben häufig noch vor sich haben
meistens in dem jungen alter zwischen 20
bis 50 jahren und häufig nach einem
vorhergegangenen eher milden akut
verlauf dann entwickeln sich mit abstand
von ein bis manchmal auch drei monaten
die longo wird symptome die sehr
heterogen sind und da nicht mal
unbedingt den des verlaufs entsprechen
ich möchte ihnen gerne eine klinische
beispiele an die hand geben mit denen
wir es in der rehaklinik zu tun haben
ich erinnere mich an den 40-jährigen
triathlet er einen leichten verlauf
hatte und jetzt ist schon ein langsamer
spaziergang von 20 minuten eine
herausforderung es fast für ihn nicht zu
bewältigen die infektion war im april
2020 die 35-jährige mutter haben mit
zwei kindern kann im erstklass selbst
vielleicht die hausaufgaben vorlesen sie
kann ihn aber nicht bei der lösung
helfen weil sie leider den den inhalt
gar nicht versteht der 25 jährige
student muss leider wieder anfangen die
grundrechenarten zu lernen weil auch das
vergessen hat die 42 jährige
krankenschwester überflutet ihre küche
weise leider vergessen hat dass sie zum
abspülen den wasserhahn gemacht hat ich
könnte ihnen noch tausende solcher
beispiele nennen und ich denke es wird
auch in vielen berichten deutlich das
sind alles menschen die vorher so gut
wie keine vorerkrankungen hatten hier
ein ganz normales leben geführt haben
und die jetzt durch lang probiert massiv
in ihrem alltagsleben in ihrer familie
in ihrem arbeitsfeld eingeschränkt sind
die symptome sind sehr vielfältig bis zu
200 verschiedene long kugel symptome
gibt es und die setzen sich in
unterschiedlichen varianten zusammen das
heißt ich ein kupon kugel patient
gleicht dem anderen im schlimmsten fall
die diagnostik ist aufwendig es gibt
nicht den einen marker den wir bestimmen
sondern die versorgung von longo wird
patienten ist aufwendig und zeitintensiv
um nur einige wenige symptome zu nennen
die die patienten aber sehr
beeinträchtigen möchte ich einige
aufzählen dazu zählt die massive
erschöpfung die fertig symptomatik die
bis zum mfs führen kann die
beeinträchtigung der atem mich an den
spielt bei vielen patienten auch wenn
sie gar nicht im krankenhaus war sich
aber trotzdem eine schon atmung
angeeignet haben eine massive rolle und
stört die leistungsentwicklung
beziehungsweise den kraft- und
konditionsaufbau wir haben es mit
kognitiven defiziten zu tun die zum teil
demenz ähnlich sind bei jungen menschen
er hat klagen über gelenk und
muskelschmerzen die nicht auf
schmerzmittel reagieren wo kaum
therapiemöglichkeiten zur verfügung
stehen und man kann sich vorstellen dass
solche patienten die optisch unversehrt
aussehen die häufig sehr sportlich sind
und dennoch krank und arbeitsunfähig
dass sich da eine gewisse hilflosigkeit
breit macht und auch ängste und
depressionen hinzu kommen es wäre fatal
zu sagen und kugelt zeit schlicht und
einfach ein rein psychosomatische
krankheitsbild selbstverständlich ist
die abgrenzung dieser diagnosen gerade
sein vor bestehende depression oder
ängste zum tragen kommen sicher
schwierig aber gerade gibt es eine
aktuelle studie in der nachgewiesen
wurde dass die graue substanz im gehirn
da wo die nervenzellen sitzen durch oder
nach einer co at 19 infektionen
vermindert wird und auch die größe des
gehirns sich reduziert möglicherweise
eine ursache für die kognitiven
einschränkungen dieser patienten die
dauer von longo wird ist unklar
aus der klinischen erfahrung wissen wir
dass zwölf monate weiter folgeschäden
nach einer kurve 19 infektion keine
seltenheit sind aber man kann nicht den
cut sagen wann die lohngruppe zum tomate
wirklich beendet ist wir haben es also
mit einer chronischen bisher noch nicht
heilbaren krankheit zu tun deren ursache
noch nicht vollständig geklärt haben und
dementsprechend auch keine medikamentöse
therapie gibt aber und das ist sehr
wichtig wir können die symptome lindern
wir haben mittlerweile zwei jahre
erfahrungen im rehabilitativen bereich
und haben verschiedenste möglichkeiten
eine symptomlinderung herbeizuführen und
den patienten zu vermitteln wie man mit
lungo witt leben kann das heißt diese
symptome müssen aber zunächst erkannt
werden konnte wird muss als krankheit
benannt werden und die betroffenen
müssen dann schnell eine therapie
zugeführt werden weil je länger die
patienten mit diesen symptomen sich
bleiben desto eher die
qualifizierungsphase geben und desto
schwerer sind diese menschen denn auch
wieder in ihren alltag und ihre mit
ihren beruf einzugliedern das heißt wir
brauchen eine breite an richter
aufklärungskampagne über das
krankheitsbild longkou wird und gerade
wenn wir jetzt über lockerungen sprechen
ist es parallel gesehen extrem wichtig
dass wir diese berichterstattung und
diese aufklärung vorantreiben und das
ist auch ein appell an die medien an sie
dass wir hier für aufklärung sorgen und
den menschen erklären dass es mittel und
kurt auf sich hat bei vollständig
geimpften mit einer durchbruchs
infektion hat oder es jetzt in einer
israelischen studie herausgekommen dass
das risiko lankowitz zu erleiden um 68
prozent reduziert ist ein argument was
denke ich sehr sehr schlagend ist von
kobe patienten können nicht die betten
der akutkrankenhäuser und
intensivstation aber sie drohen die
erwerbsunfähigkeit statistiken zu füllen
und wenn hunderttausende betroffene die
leistungsträger unserer gesellschaft
dauerhaft arbeits oder erwerbsunfähig
bleiben müssen wir uns über diese
gesellschaftlichen und ökonomischen
folgen gedanken machen
denn im dezember 2021 unter der
schirmherrschaft des
bundesgesundheitsministers gegründete
ärzte und ärztinnen verwandlung co wird
hat sich das ziel gesetzt forschung
versorgung aus bildung und aufklärung
zum thema lankowitz voranzutreiben denn
wir müssen einfach eingestehen long
kuwait ist nicht die spitze des eisbergs
sondern ist der teil unter der
wasseroberfläche
vielen dank dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen
ich habe schon einige im saal notiert
ich habe auch zahlreiche fragen online
noch einmal zur erinnerung auch im sinne
der fairness stellen sie bitte eine
frage gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage
eventuell gibt es auch die chance wenn
sie eine andere frage noch haben noch
mal dran zu kommen ich starte mit einer
frage online gestellt von andreas reuter
vom aldi hauptstadtstudio und er fragte
den minister nach ihrer düsteren
beschreibung der nagel reichen die nach
dem neuen infektionsschutzgesetz
möglichen maßnahmen überhaupt aus um die
pandemie zu kontrollieren ganz
unabhängig davon wer die maßnahmen
verhängen darf oder muss fragt ihr
ja die schnelle antwort ist ja sind die
maßnahmen die wir immer einsetzen wenn
es schwere ausbrüche gibt oder die
residenzstadt was kann abstände dann
impfnachweis test nachweise genießen das
nachweis und hygiene konzepte das sind
die maßnahmen die wir ansetzen die
einzige maßnahme die nach neuem fsg
nicht mehr möglich wäre
die aber nach altem fsg möglich gewesen
wäre werde kontakt begrenzung
kontaktsperre und auf die haben wir
verzichtet dieser zum schluss auch kaum
mehr eingesetzt worden lässt sich auch
sehr schwer kontrollieren somit die
schnelle antwort ja das neue fsg würde
ausreichen aber das gesetz ist wird das
neue fsg ist nur so gut wie die landtage
die es anwenden
denn dann machen wir im saal weiter bei
der kollege in der mitte bei ihnen
genommen
hatte ich vom nachrichtenportal motten
verladen monaten gibt es berichte
darüber dass gerade jugendliche an
depressionen und angstzuständen kroner
bedingt vor allem leiden im
koalitionsvertrag haben sie auch unter
anderem darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass
sie hier
handlungsbedarf die bedarfsplanung
reformieren wollen da gibt es dazu schon
konkrete pläne
die frage ist noch demnach der
bedarfsplanung im krankenhaus und
planung der für die mentale gesundheit
für therapeutische plätze wir haben in
deutschland gerne stark entschuldigung
haben in deutschland ja einen großen
mangel an therapieplätzen
die bildungsplanung in der
psychotherapie ok in der tat daran
werden wir arbeiten das gehört zu den
vielen projekten die wir jetzt in den
nächsten monaten beginnen wir werden
also sehr schnell jetzt ein gesetz
vorliegen zur finanzierung der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung
gewähren gesetz vorwiegend zur triage
regelung wir werden ein gesetz vorlegen
zum geboren und wir werden ein gesetz
vorlegen wo es darum geht die
krankenhausversorgung neu zu
strukturieren aber auch zur
bedarfsplanung in der psychotherapie wir
haben wir das problem dass wir also eine
relativ kurze therapeuten dichte haben
aber gleichzeitig an unterversorgung für
diejenigen die eine in also eine
versorgung benötigen für eine krankheit
die also erhebliche risikofaktoren mit
sich bringt die schwereren fälle
bekommen schlecht die therapieplatz zu
bekommen erst
kommen häufig noch einen ersten termin
aber dann keine folgetermine mehr und
daran wird gearbeitet
jetzt haben sie eben noch mal vor
schwereren schlimmeren herz brand was
wollen sie denn tun dass gerade die
jungen menschen
dass der sommer nicht noch genommen wird
gerade im hinblick auf die mentale
gesundheit
die frage nach der sommer will kommt ja
auch war die wir hatten ja im letzten
sommer hatten wir so gut wie keine fälle
da war die fahrzeuge zum teil
einstellung und die frage ist ob es
dieses jahr auch wieder erwarten können
ob wir an und so unbeschwerten sommer
wieder erwarten können wie beim letzten
jahr dass man kaum fälle hat einstellige
zahl so dass ein sehr normales leben
möglich ist und da war sie neben
wissenschaftler daraufhin wie zum
beispiel christian drosten aber auch
andere dass also der wert der omicron
variante so hoch ist dass das sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist und daher müssten
wir dann auch im sommer mit bestimmten
maßnahmen also rechnen müssen wir also
reagieren dafür wird das
infektionsschutzgesetz wären das also
entsprechendes maß überschreitet
natürlich zur verfügung stellen und im
herbst sind die probleme ja eben schon
beschrieben worden aber es ist leider so
weil er in deutschland hohen zahl der
ungeimpften
ist die pandemie noch nicht vorbei
eine frage zum thema kinder und
jugendliche stellt auch daniel pontzen
online vom zdf er fragt den minister
also er weist darauf hin er seit langem
berichteten kinder fachärzte über
schwerwiegende folgen der korona
maßnahmen für kinder und jugendliche
während der anteil der schweren verläufe
niedriger ist deswegen für seine frage
ist warum sie das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz trotzdem explizit
die möglichkeit vor tests in schulen und
kitas auch nach dem 20 märz fortzusetzen
das infektionsgeschehen also in dieser
altersgruppe konsequenter zu überwachen
als in anderen altersgruppen ist die
frage an sie herr lauterbach und eine
frage richtet sich an händler
nach den vorliegenden daten nach zwei
jahren pandemie fragt er wie viele
kinder sind in deutschland an cholera
gestorben
und was ist auf grundlage dieser daten
für kinder schwieriger die korona
erkrankung oder die sogenannten
collateral folgen
ja ich habe mal an also ist es
tatsächlich von den fragenden
korrekt beschrieben worden dass also die
noch das neue infektionsschutzgesetz
tests für also kinder ermöglicht das ist
die also das was ich also sozusagen mit
meinem buch machen hier sondern
vorgeschlagen haben dass die möglichkeit
besteht das ist ja keine pflicht zum
testen wenn jetzt die landesregierung
zum beispiel die position vertreten
wurden dass dieser test zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht notwendig sind und dass
möglicherweise psychologischen schäden
für kinder für die test größer wären
also als der nutzen also für die von den
test für die kinder die ja auch
erkranken können und die eltern und das
partygeschehen dann muss die
landesregierung so vorgehen dass kann
die landesregierung habe ich entscheiden
nicht der landtag das ist ja eine
maßnahme die noch nicht auf den hotspot
bezogen ist nun auf den landtag aber
tatsächlich lässt das
infektionsschutzgesetz diese möglichkeit
zu schreibt sie aber nicht vor meine
persönliche meinung ist dass beim
jetzigen infektionsgeschehen solche test
sehr sinnvoll sein können und mit dazu
beigetragen haben dass tatsächlich die
entwicklung der fallzahlen bei den
kindern sich etwas günstiger entwickelt
als in anderen altersgruppen
obwohl natürlich die belastung groß ist
aber das ist dann durch die jeweiligen
landesregierungen zu entscheiden
ja die zahl wenn man in den gestrigen
wochenbericht reinschaut dann sind uns
also dem robert-koch-institut 57
todesfälle bekannt von kindern zwischen
null und 19 jahren und die frage die
sich daran anschließt ich finde das
ehrlich gesagt
keinen wirklich wahr lieben vergleich
wir müssen doch davon ausgehen von zwei
dingen das eine ist der fall das
natürlich die kinder auch eben
erwachsene anstecken können und
natürlich auch eltern und großeltern
anstecken können und es gibt ja fälle wo
natürlich auch leider gottes dann im
rahmen dieser ansteckung auch eltern und
großeltern von kindern verstorben sind
was ja nun eine große traumatisierung
ist insofern finde ich die zahl von
kindern die verstorben ist die
glücklicherweise nicht sehr hoch ist
obwohl ich nach wie vor der ansicht bin
dass jedes verstorbene kind eines zu
viel ist und das ganz deutlich zu sagen
ich finde diese diese vergleiche hinken
einfach und wenn sie selber kinder haben
also ich meine kinder sind jetzt schon
aus der schule raus aber natürlich kenne
ich viele menschen die kinder haben die
kinder haben eine starke selbst kraft
also die machen inzwischen die tests
quasi von alleine die kommen damit klar
die kinder sind sehr intelligent vor
allem natürlich kinder wenn die in
vernünftigen wohnverhältnissen sind wir
wissen alle dass diese pandemie
insbesondere diejenigen trifft die eben
in
verhältnissen leben die nicht sehr schön
sind in den schwachen bildungsschichten
das wissen wir alles und was wir aus
dieser pandemie lernen sollten wäre doch
das für die wohnverhältnisse dieser
menschen verbessern dass wir die die
bildung dieser menschen verbessern und
dafür müssen schulen eben auch
ausgerichtet sein so dass sie eben auch
im falle von solchen pandemien wenn etwa
schulen zum beispiel nur noch teilweise
betrieben werden können dass sie auch
mit dem entsprechenden homeschooling so
versorgt werden können ich denke wir
müssen die verhältnisse so schaffen dass
wir den kindern ein gutes leben
ermöglichen und eine gute bildung
ermöglichen und sie sollten einfach froh
sein dass die krankheit nicht so viele
kinder so schwer krank macht und die
belastungen sind vielfältig die zu
psychischen folgen für die
nächste frage haben sagen hat herr grimm
von uns aus gesehen auf der linken seite
lauterbach ich hätte eine frage an sie
haben ja gerade ausgeführt dass sie
damit rechnen dass die landtage bald
strengere maßnahmen wieder einführen
werden müssen ich wollte sie fragen ob
dazu dann auch das maske tragen in
schulen gehört ist es möglich nach dem
entwurf des infektionsschutzgesetzes den
sie mit herrn bush man arbeitet ja
das war die antwort also ist ja so in
die genau die schnelle antwort ist ja
die war so schnell dass ich so schnell
nicht die frage gefunden habt ihr dazu
passen könnte nämlich von themen steffen
der auch noch mal zum thema masken
pflicht fragt er schreibt die mp cam pk
mitte februar habe eine masken pflicht
insbesondere in geschlossenen räumen und
publikums einrichtungen gefordert also
an mehr orten als der entwurf jetzt
vorsehe so schreibt er ist wieso wird
dieser weitreichenden forderungen nicht
entsprochen ist die frage das ist ja so
nicht sondern also in den
gebietskörperschaften
beispielsweise städte landkreise und
ganzes bundesland wenn das
infektionsgeschehen danach ist dann die
also das infektionsgeschehen dynamisch
ist also starke anstieg der instanz oder
hohe intelligenz und gleichzeitig lokal
bedrohte überlastung der
gesundheitsversorgung ist natürlich auch
die masken pflicht in innenräumen
nutzbar die maske pflicht ist ja wie
eine von den vier maßnahmen die unter
diesen umständen
ermöglicht werden und dann kann das vom
landtag beschlossen werden
damit halte ich auch ein gruß an herrn
klöckner ihre frage für beantwortet
ansonsten bitte nochmal melden und wir
machen im saal weiter bei herrn gabriel
es auf der von uns aus gesehen rechten
seite man hat das gefühl ist für den
deutschlandfunk
eine frage an einen wiener herr
lauterbach hat gesagt dass das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz und die maßnahmen
dass das ausreichen würde um ich sag
jetzt mal sinngemäß um das pandemie
geschehen zu kontrollieren
teilen sie diese einschätzung und wenn
nicht wo müsste dir immer noch das
infektionsschutzgesetz um es dann
nachbesserungen geben also das
wesentliche im infektionsschutzgesetz
ist ja die möglichkeit dass man
ausbrüche eindämmt und diese möglichkeit
ist gegeben wir müssen immer vor augen
haben dass die infektion schutzmaßnahmen
ja in erster linie vor ort getroffen
werden also wenn sie sich erinnern vor
etwa anderthalb jahren habe ich an
derselben stelle ja appelliert an die
landräte landrätin oberbürgermeister
bürgermeister die er letztlich dafür
sorge tragen müssen dass in ihren
gemeinden die entsprechende
infektionsschutz maßnahmen durchgeführt
werden wir wissen inzwischen dass
wussten wir ganz am anfang dieser
pandemie nicht dass masken eine große
wirkung haben das heißt also dieser
schutzmechanismus der masken der kann
gar nicht hoch genug eingeschätzt werden
das ist sehr sehr wichtig dass das
weiter möglich ist und es ist natürlich
so dass im rahmen von ausbrüchen die die
entsprechenden gesundheitsämter eben
auch den baum von ausbruch
untersuchungen bestimmte einrichtungen
schließen können diese möglichkeit
besteht nach wie vor das ist sehr sehr
wichtig und ich denke eine wirklich ganz
entscheidende was wir gelernt haben in
den letzten beiden jahren ist ja
maßnahmen müssen umgesetzt werden auch
das hatte ich sehr sehr häufig glaube
ich hier angesprochen die maßnahmen
müssen vor ort umgesetzt werden dann
erst sind sie wirksam und das ist sehr
sehr wichtig noch eine nachfrage
vielleicht auch an herrn lauterbach weil
sie ja vor anfangs auch die kriterien
für die gebietskörperschaften für die
sogenannten hot spots erwähnt haben
riskieren sie mit diesem gesetz nicht
eigentlich dass jedes land für sich
selbst entscheiden kann als ob in
zwanzigster märz bzw nach dieser
übergangsfrist ab dem zweiten amerikaner
berlin sagen wir sind gar keinen hotspot
wir haben zwar wo inzidenz aber die
krankenhäuser sind nicht überlastet
während brandenburg ähnliche inzidenz
und sagt wir haben eine überlastung
riskieren sie nicht da weil sie auch
explizit betont haben in der
vergangenheit dass sie absichtlich keine
grenzwerte festgelegt haben dass das
letztendlich tür und tor öffnet für ihn
hätte zum beispiel kirchliche
entscheidungen der einzelnen
landesregierungen
ist eine wichtige frage ist wäre einfach
nicht medizinisch möglich gewesen hier
grenzwerte zu nennen es geht einfach
nicht also wenn sie aussagen ich bloß
see oder sein beispiel also nennen sie
einen grenzwert von einer inzidenz von
zum beispiel
50 dann kann das bei der delta variante
kann das ein sinnvoller grenzwert sei
aber für omicron natürlich nicht und es
ist das absurd somit also weil wir jetzt
sehr unterschiedliche varianten haben
ist ein einzelner grenzwert varianten
unabhängig nicht mehr möglich früher war
so etwas denkbar wo die varianten alle
mehr oder weniger also sehr nahe bei der
wo hahn variante noch lagen bei der
omicron freiheit da haben wir zum ersten
mal an anderen serotyp und wie auch in
anderen infektionskrankheiten anderer
serotyp andere grenzt wird somit also
konnte man das nicht mehr fortführen das
hat zur konsequenz da es keinen
einheitlichen grenzwert mehr geben kann
dass die landesregierung spielräume
haben wenn es die basismaßnahmen
betrifft und wenn es die hotspot
regelung betrifft haben die
landesparlamente diese entsprechende
spielräume aber anders kann man es nicht
machen was ich mir wünschen würde wäre
das die also landesregierungen sich
einige auf ein einheitliches vorgehen im
rahmen des neuen
infektionsschutzgesetzes
beispielsweise bei mpk treffen denn der
war also das gesetz eine solche vorgabe
nicht mehr ermöglicht bleibt sie aber
möglich im rahmen von freiwilligen
übereinkünften und ganz offen gesagt so
funktionieren ja auch jetzt die mpk
beschlüsse beschlüsse sind im prinzip
einigungen darauf was man gemeinsam
gedenkt zu tun oft nicht ausreichend
gemeinsam umgesetzt aber der
grundgedanke genau der
es gibt online auch fragen zu den
sogenannten hot spots und zum zur
entwicklung des infektionsgeschehen
scheinbar ja ich nehme zwei fragen
zusammen sascha meyer dpa fragt mit
welchem schub beim infektionsgeschehen
rechnen sie nach den modellierungen wenn
ab 20 märz fast alle maßnahmen wie 2g 3g
und weitere wegfallen ist dann eine 7
tage incidents von 2000 und mehr
vorstellbar und wäre das vertretbar und
gernot heller fragt nach sie sagten es
gebe jetzt schon hotspots und anderen
ort stehe das kurz bevor wo ist das
konkret und nach welchen kriterien wird
dort gegengesteuert ist die frage
vielen dank zunächst einmal in der tat
nach der öffnung könnte es sein dass die
residenz weiter steigt und dann kann uns
eine inzidenz von 2000 natürlich nicht
zufrieden lassen somit appelliere ich
noch einmal an den länder die also
möglichkeit nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz war als jetzt
vorzubehalten die länder haben ja noch
also in der übergangszeit die bestehende
rechtsverordnung die gilt bis zum
zweiten april und in der zwischenzeit
zwischen also sozusagen dem zwanzigsten
märz und dem zweiten april können die
landesregierungen mit den
landesparlamenten
gemeinsam das neue
infektionsstation schutzgesetz bereits
benutzten um also dann
rechtsverordnungen zu entwickeln die die
alte bestehende rechtsverordnung
ersetzen somit kommt es nicht zu einer
zeit wo keine regelungen bestehen
sondern die so lang wie die länder haben
ja noch bestehende rechtsordnungen und
können bis zu zwei neue
rechtsverordnungen beschließen es gibt
keinen fall wo nichts gilt also es ist
nicht so das war ja auch zum teil
diskutiert worden brauchen wir einen
kompletten also rückzug von den
kollektiven schutzmaßnahmen und das
ganze ist dann nur noch in der
verantwortung des einzelnen werde er
sich nicht infizieren will muss er maske
tragen oder sich impfen kollektiv
passiert nichts mehr das ist nicht
vorgesehen sondern die bestehenden
rechtsordnungen gelten noch neue
rechtsverordnung und können bis zum 20
14 beschlossen werden wo gibt es derzeit
trotz bord sei ja das
infektionsgeschehen ist dynamisch dass
ich sehe das an vielen orten ein
beispiel ist zum beispiel die
entwicklung in köln in köln ist durch
das feiern des karnevals offenbar die
genaue beschreibung der ursache ist noch
nicht möglich die wissenschaftliche
analyse findet statt aber kolleginnen
und kollegen von der universitätsklinik
köln
teilen wir mit dass aus so wegen der
altersverteilung der ausbrüche und auch
der lokalisation der ausbrüche
wahrscheinlich ein zusammenhang mit dem
karneval zu sehen ist nun gut wir dem
auch immer sei das also
infektionsgeschehen das ausgesprochen
dynamisch wir haben sehr ruhig zu setzen
und wir haben natürlich auch eine
situation wo die lokale
gesundheitsversorgung belastet ist es
mussten in der kölner uniklinik
zahlreiche planbare eingriffe abgesagt
werden konnten nicht durchgeführt werden
weil die ausfälle in der klinik so
dramatisch war dazu kommen mehr omikron
infizierte in die klinik da könnte ich
mir schon vorstellen dass jetzt schon
also von der landesregierung nrw an
einer entsprechenden hotspot regelung
gearbeitet werden sollte die das neue
recht dann nutzt also eben die ich werde
es noch mit einem satz sagen ich
persönlich finde es problematisch
wenn also über vermeintlich nicht
bestehende möglichkeiten geklagt wird
solange man gute gegebenen möglichkeiten
auch nicht im ansatz komplett nutzt
dann machen wir im fall weiter bei der
kollegin in der mitte
kerstin baltzer ard-hauptstadtstudio
herr minister seit seit dem ausbruch der
korona pandemie setzen sie sich massiv
ein dafür dass es maßnahmen gibt die uns
alle schützen sollen seitdem sie
minister sind machen sie das natürlich
auch jetzt erklären sie uns heute dass
die omikron variante
gefährlicher ist als vielleicht viele
von uns denken und gleichzeitig setzten
sie einen einen infektionsschutzgesetz
durch das eben mehr freiheit auf jeden
fall zulässt und wenn ich daran denke
wenn er gut er ist in einer koalition
eingebunden dann sagen sie mir nein also
doch aber es ist sogar mein vorschlag
gewesen ich bin gar nicht auf ein
buschmann zugegangen sondern es war mein
vorschlag erklären sie mir bitte diesen
sinneswandel und eine frage an herrn
wieder wie viele der gestorbenen auf den
intensivstationen sind geimpft wissen
sie das
vielen dank für die frage zunächst
einmal ich glaube dass wir in den
wochen und monaten wo wir die panne
jetzt gemeinsam versucht haben zu
meistern seit die ampel regierung
regiert man erst mal festhalten muss
dass wir sie del tabelle relativ schnell
zurückfahren konnten und die omikron
wähle nicht so dramatisch gewesen ist
wie in vielen nachbarländern und dass
wir daher also sterbezahlen gehabt haben
die im vergleich zu nachbarländern zu
anderen ländern niedriger gewesen sind
somit man kann auf jeden fall also
kritik an den maßnahmen die wir
getroffen haben wir gemacht haben also
äußern aber am ergebnis gemessen ist der
vorsichtige kurs der sehr stark also
auch verankert gewesen ist in den in der
begleitung durch den experten hat mit
dem ich ja sehr intensiv
zusammenarbeitet und auch anderen
experten mit denen ich bilaterale
zusammenarbeit vom format des neuen
beispiel christian drosten stellen viele
andere welt aber dieser kurs im großen
ganzen bisher dahingehend aufgegangen
dass wir relativ schnell ein booster
kampagne hochfahren konnten die dafür
gesorgt hat dass viele ältere nicht
schwer erkrankt sind und ich sterbe
zahlen sind nicht so hoch gewesen wie
sie gewesen wären auf andere uns
umgebende länder schaut
beim infektionsschutzgesetz war eine
voraussetzung die dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz die also
rechtliche also prüfung überlebt im
rahmen einer neuen variante werden es
kann eine neue variante gegeben hätte
hätte man vieles von dem was man früher
gemacht hat einfach bestehen lassen
können aber das jetzt so etwas kommt wie
die hotspot regelung und die knüpfung an
die entwicklung der hospitalisierung
oder der belastung des krankheits wegen
des gesundheitswesens das liegt einfach
daran dass also von also rechtlicher
seite aber auch von politischer seite
die frage gestellt wird sind die
maßnahmen die wir bisher ergriffen haben
sind die noch zu vertreten wenn bei
einer uni konstante objektiver weise
gilt dass sie nicht so schwer verläuft
somit hätten wir also wenn es die
omikron war ja da nie gegeben hätte
hätten wir haben infektionsschutzgesetz
wie bis jetzt hatten kaum etwas
verändern müssen aber ich kann nicht
realistischer weise das
infektionsschutzgesetz so weiter haben
wie es ist als eine variante dominierte
die eine viel höhere sterblichkeit hatte
wenn ich eine variante habe die das
nicht hat somit ist der hauptgrund
weshalb man das infektionsschutzgesetz
neu schreiben musste als es jetzt
auslief und nicht einfach verlängern
konnte dass wir jetzt eine variante
haben die zumindest für die geimpften
die umgeben ist das was anderes nicht so
dramatisch verläuft und mit dieser
medizinischen gegebenheit habe ich
arbeiten müssen ich drücke das mal sehr
also klar aus also dass man also da
nicht also
falsch versteht oder das
bestehende haben dass die dinge sind
kompliziert aber nun muss es simpel
ausdrücken also das
infektionsschutzgesetz was wir jetzt
gemacht haben trägt in erster linie der
tatsache rechnung dass die omikron
variante in erster linie wirklich
tödlich gefährlich für ungeimpfte aber
nicht mehr für alle
und nicht mehr für alle in dem maße es
ist daher nicht also eine reaktion in
erster linie auf die wünsche der fdp das
muss man klar so sagen
ich kann ihnen die zahl nicht genau
sagen da würde ich sie bitten wenn sie
sich noch mal unser pressestelle wenden
wie viele menschen jetzt genau
verstorben sind aber selbstverständlich
gibt es auch fälle wo menschen die
geimpft sind versterben aber wenn sie
sich die effektivität anschauen sehen
sie eben dass der impfschutz sehr hoch
ist den tod immer noch 90 prozent und
das heißt also sie werden sicher weniger
menschen auf intensivstationen
versterben die geimpft sind als fläche
die umkämpft sind weil der impfschutz
ebenso hoch ist sie dürfen bei diesen
absoluten zahlen aber eines nie
vergessen darauf weisen wir auch immer
hin und das ist so eine statistische
betrachtungsweise es sind ja inzwischen
und 75 prozent also sozusagen drei
viertel der deutschen sind ja
vollständig geimpft das sind dreimal
mehr menschen in seinem land geimpft als
ungeimpft und das müssen sie natürlich
auch ein berechnen wenn sie den anteil
derjenigen die die dann auch intensiv
dazu legen dass die
grundgesamtheit der menschen ist eben
dreimal so hoch als sie dürfen nicht nur
die absoluten zahlen sehen sondern sie
müssen auch die zahlen sehen der
grundgesamtheit die dahinter steckt aber
wie gesagt bitte fragen sie in der
pressestelle habe ich hab's nicht im
kopf
das gilt dann auch für die neue zürcher
zeitung die die gleiche frage gestellt
hatte wir haben es jetzt gleich vor und
wir haben eine nachfolgeveranstaltung
weil wir ein bisschen später angefangen
haben wäre mein vorschlag dass wir bis
10 nach elf noch machen wenn unsere
gäste die zeit haben ich habe noch drei
fragen hier im sagen und hat fragen zu
tests und zur einrichtungs gezogenen
impfpflicht online die ich gern bis
dahin noch schaffen würde und ich starte
mal mit den online fragen zu den tests
die zwei zusammen patrick hollstein von
apotheke adhoc fragt wie es mit den
bürger tests nach dem 20 märz weitergeht
und wie sichergestellt wird dass test
stellen auch bei geringer nachfrage
weiter betrieben werden können und
thorsten maibaum vom deutschen
ärzteblatt fragt das sollte bis ende
februar eine liste mit qualitativ
hochwertigen corona schnell tester
arbeiten diese liege bisher nicht vor
warum ist das nicht der fall dann soll
es die liste geben ist eine frage ja
sagen zu sagen wir wir werden natürlich
bürger tests weiter zur verfügung
stellen über die hohe inzidenz ist ja
eben schon gesprochen worden und
insbesondere kann man natürlich das
infektionsgeschehen nicht ableiten was
also grundlage für hot spot definitionen
ist ohne dass getestet wird von daher
werden die tests weiter angeboten werden
und die frage nach dem paar das bei hat
wertvolle wichtige analysen gemacht wo
die also empfindlichkeit der test gegen
die delta variante und andere varianten
im vergleich zur nikon varianten
ausgewertet worden sind diese ergebnisse
sind so meines wissens weitestgehend
abgeschlossen
zwischenberichte sind mir mündlich
vorgetragen worden ich kann allerdings
hier nicht genau sagen wann das bei die
entsprechenden auswertungen
veröffentlicht dann machen wir weiter
hat ein frauen magma ja
ja ich habe nur eine wissens frage wie
ist das denn mit den ganzen regelungen
zum beispiel der arbeitsschutzverordnung
gelten die weiter oder nicht es gibt ja
viele bereiche die man sich jetzt was
ist es denn nun demnächst
jahrzehnt lang für die frage in der tat
solche regelungen gelten weiter sie
werden jetzt noch einmal spezifiziert
das passiert aber in einem anderen
gesetz über welches in der nächsten
woche auch abstimmen werden im sechs
gesetzt
dann gibt es fragen online gestellter
einrichtungs bezogenen in pflicht ich
starte mit denen von mathis feldhoff vom
zdf erfragt
mittlerweile scheine klar dass das virus
trotz impfung übertragbar ist was macht
da die einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
noch für einen sinn ist seine frage und
die zweite dazu befürchten sie nicht
dass durch die impfpflicht die ohnehin
angespannte situation in kliniken pflege
arztpraxen noch schlimmer durch
die schlechte nachricht wir sehen jetzt
wieder vermehrt ausbrüche in
pflegeeinrichtungen auch mit
sterbefällen und die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht will dem begegnen
wir wollen den begegnen mit der
leistungsbezogenen pflicht
die übertragung ist natürlich auch
möglich wenn man geimpft ist das ist
klar aber sie ist einfach weniger
wahrscheinlich somit derjenige der
frisch geimpft ist
und gar gepustet der kann sich auch
infizieren nur dass es eben dort nicht
weniger wahrscheinlich dass er sich
überhaupt infiziert und wenn er sich
infiziert ist nach einigen studien auch
deutlich weniger ansteckend und nicht so
lange ansteckend somit also ist das eine
wichtige maßnahme das
infektionsgeschehen
insgesamt dort also zu verbessern aber
es ersetzt natürlich nicht die
zusätzlichen notwendigen maßnahmen in
den
wohngruppen gelten und die in dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz ja auch incident
unabhängig festgeschrieben sind auch
möchte ich noch einmal hinweisen dass
also tests und auch masken sich hier
also vor gegeben werden können
unabhängig von der insel entgegen den
einrichtungen wo vorgruppen versorgt
werden krankenhäuser und
pflegeeinrichtungen oder ambulante
pflege und die
genau wie die frage gehen pflegekräfte
hier verloren in den meisten
bundesländern ist die zahl derer die
tatsächlich in der pflege arbeiten und
nicht geimpft sind nicht nicht sehr hoch
es sind meistens weniger als zehn
prozent und da hoffen wir tatsächlich
durch überzeugungsarbeit auch durch die
also aus meiner sicht sehr zu loben de
arbeite einrichtungsleiter drinnen und
leiter das noch abzuwenden also dass das
in vielen fällen auch gelingen es gibt
natürlich auch bundesländer war wird es
schwerer werden zum beispiel sachsen da
ist so sehr schwer ich habe jetzt am
dienstag ja einen besuch in also sachsen
vorgenommen da bin ich in einer
pflegeeinrichtung gewesen habe auch in
mit ärzten und ärzten und pflegekräften
dort in der universität gesprochen und
die lage ist dort tatsächlich sehr
prekär da wird aber die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht entsprechend auch
mit großer vorsicht umgesetzt und es
werden hart übergangszeiten ermöglicht
die also
besonders ministerin petra köpping
entwickelt hat und ich glaube dass das
auch eine vorgehensweise ist mit
augenmaß so dass für das problem auch
dort herrschen
johanna wolff von der rheinischen post
fragt auch zum thema in pflicht ihre
frage ist in österreich hat seine in
pflicht wieder ausgesetzt wird es nicht
immer schwieriger der bevölkerung eine
impfpflicht noch zu vermitteln damit
meint sie allerdings habe ich das gefühl
er die allgemeine impfpflicht und stellt
auch die frage ob sie befürchten dass
unter mitarbeitern heim kliniken ein
gefühl der ungleichbehandlung wächst
wenn sie zum impfen verpflichtet werden
die einführung der allgemeinen pflicht
aber nicht vorankommt
zu sechs die lage in österreich ist die
dort hat man das so gesetz so formuliert
das ist zum einen sehr stark auf die
omikron variante ausgerichtet war was
ich von anfang an für einen fehler
gehalten habe ich habe den
gesundheitsminister
also diese bedenken auch vorgetragen
als wir uns getroffen haben also im
rahmen
eines treffens des europäischen rats in
lyon weil die ausrichtung der endlich
auf eine spezifische variante ist nicht
zielführend
schwierig und entspricht auch nicht dem
problem dass wir zu lösen haben sinnvoll
ist tatsächlich damit zu arbeiten dass
sie im allgemeinen endlich auf die
möglichen varianten ausgerichtet ist mit
der mit denen wir im herbst rechnung ist
somit gab es zwei probleme es war von
mikron ausgerichtet war das kind auf die
jetztige welle ja quasi schon dem ende
zugeht zumindest in österreich
und dann kommt auch noch dazu
dass eben hier die also
begründung so formuliert war das also zu
jedem zeitpunkt also die
verfassungsmäßigkeit überprüft werden
muss anhand des pandemischen geschehens
zu diesem zeitpunkt so dass die
impfpflicht eingesetzt und wieder
ausgesetzt und wieder eingesetzt werden
kann also sehr schwieriges verfahren aus
meiner sicht und ich hatte mich immer
sehr zurück mit kritik an kroner
maßnahmen die außerhalb von deutschland
gemacht haben werden weil man die länder
also sie also nicht kritisieren kann man
kennt sich nicht genug aus aber hier hat
man aus meiner sicht zu viele
zugeständnisse gemacht an diejenigen die
sich der impfpflicht also widersetzt
haben wenn man eine impfpflicht macht
dann muss sie qualitativ hochwertig sein
und muss funktionieren das muss dann ein
gutes handwerk sein dann muss man sich
auch also überall so bedenken die
vertretbar sind plausibel sind aber
medizinisch nicht haltbar sind
hinwegsetzen
dann machen wir im saal weiter bei herrn
bissige
dieses micro ist das richtige jetzt ja
medikamenten frage herr lauterbach wir
erleben gerade eine knappheit beim
wirkstoff taxi moscheen und daraus
resultierende knappheit auch bei
wichtigen medikamenten mich würde
interessieren wie kann es denn zu einer
derartigen knappheit eigentlich von
lebenswichtigen medikamenten kommen und
wie kann man sowas in zukunft an denke
ja auch vielleicht an corona medikation
verhindert werden
vielen dank gern derzeit also dass sie
die situation dass also in der
arzneimittelversorgung in eine
abhängigkeit besteht von der zulieferung
viele wirkstoffe die in deutschland
nicht mehr produziert werden das ist
etwas was wir uns in den anderen
bereichen haben nicht nur in der medizin
ich glaube dass wir im rahmen also der
krisen durch die wir jetzt gehen corona
pandemie noch lange nicht zu ende
aber auch also keine krise genauer
gesagt der verbrecherischen krieg den
putin gegen das ukrainische folge unter
bruch des völkerrechtes derzeit führt da
sehen wir ja auch dass es zu ausfällen
kommt war lieferketten einbrechen
meine einschätzung ist dass wir uns
besser vorbereiten müssen auf solche
situationen und daher für kritische
medikamente schutzausrüstungen aber
gerade auch impfstoffe und auch also
wenn das also erlaubt es euch das auch
dazu führe wo es nicht mein bereich als
auch energie und rohstoffe dass wir uns
unabhängiger machen
ich glaube wir leben in einer zeit wo
klar wird dass wir in teilen eine
entflechtung des produktionsprozesses
weltweit einladen müssen
dann hat er gerade es noch eine frage ja
ich muss nochmal bei herrn wieder
nachfrage wieder ich habe sie immer auch
in den letzten zwei jahren als den
mahner wahrgenommen der relativ klare
worte gefunden hatte ich fand ihre
antwort von zum neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht ganz so
klar also deshalb nochmal die nachfrage
macht es aus ihrer sicht aus sicht des
lka sind zu diesem zeitpunkt wir erleben
gerade rekord infektions seien zu
lockern also wir haben ja gesagt dass
senioren wochenbericht dass der die
zunahme von von instanzen zum einen mit
ba2 zusammenhängt zum anderen natürlich
auch damit dass das durch die
lockerungen das verhalten der menschen
sich ändert es ist sehr sehr wichtig
dass die menschen weiterhin vorsichtig
sind wachsam sind und ich denke wenn man
den letzten beiden jahren gelernt dass
wir selber sehr sehr viele möglichkeiten
haben uns zu schützen und ich hoffe dass
diese möglichkeiten auch weiterhin in
hohem aus dem wahrgenommen werden wir
müssen wachsam bleiben und dass das
können die menschen auch tun
es gibt noch eine nachfrage online
gestellt von der ard kollegen wird er
nicht sie hätten von einer möglichen
freiwilligen übereinkunft der länder bei
der mpk gesprochen schreibt sie wie
könnte diese aussehen was ist damit
genau gemeint mit blick auf die
umsetzung der hotspot regelung wenn man
sollte er den ländern nicht vorgreifen
aber die hotspot regelungen sieht ja
jetzt vor dass also die infektions
dynamik betrachtet wird wie stark
steigen die fälle wie hoch ist die
instanz und eine kombination also mit
dem mit der lokalen überforderung des
gesundheitssystems und
in dieser kombination also wird die
hotspot regelung dann benutzt dass die
länder jetzt über einkommen und sich
also beispielsweise eine gewisse
einigkeit geben ab wann sie diese also
in möglichkeiten nutzen und also welche
dynamik zum beispiel dort also
berücksichtigt werden soll das sind
alles möglichkeiten die die länder haben
und das wäre denkbar im rahmen des mpg
schluss enz das gesetz gibt das auf
jeden fall her das gesetz also ergibt
daher dass also wir die über die
basismaßnahmen maske und testen in den
wollen raten gruppen die naumannschule
ersten schulen hinaus gehen diese vier
kriterien also dann die diese vier
maßnahmen ergriffen werden und da wäre
schon ein verständnis verständigung der
bundesländer denkbar
auf welche also ja werte man sich hier
ungefähr einigen bei der derzeitigen
pany das kann man nicht ins gesetz
schreiben war das gesetz muss für jede
variante gelten und muss für jede
dynamik gelten ist also ist somit also
nicht medizin nicht möglich dass wir in
das infektionsschutzgesetz diese regeln
hineinschreiben sonst müssen das gesetz
regelmäßig anpassen aber eine also
diskussion und einer einigung auf eu
ebene wäre aus meiner sicht durchaus
hilfreich und würde dann auch übrigens
also die rechts festigkeit solche
maßnahmen durch die landesparlamente
getroffen noch einmal stärken
dann würde ich die letzten wenigen
minuten nutzen und eine frage stellen
von charlotte kurzer pharmazeutischen
zeitung das ist ein themenwechsel sie
fragt zudem ukraine flüchtlingen und
zwar ist die frage an auch an den
minister auch schon veranlasst worden
sei dass kommunen und krankenkassen
geflüchtete aus der ukraine anspruch für
die klassischen medizinischen leistungen
gewesen sollen und wie wird diese
veranlassung rechtlich verankert sich
die fragen
ja also wir haben vielen dank wir haben
vier maßnahmen hier
initiiert und ich möchte darauf
hinweisen dass also die sind
zusammenarbeit mit dem
bundesinnenministerium gründen geschehen
ist also mit fräser im wesentlichen aber
auch mit dem auswärtigen amt das erste
ist medikamente und hilfsmittel können
ausgeführt werden und es wurde eine
allgemeine
ausfuhrgenehmigung eine pauschale aus
vor genehmigung erteilt so dass die
ausfuhr von medikamenten und also
hilfsmitteln jederzeit erfolgen kann da
sind wir auch in kontakt mit den
polnischen behörden so dass der
transport durch polen hinweg also
jederzeit möglich ist dass vater ist
verwundete verletzte können nach
deutschland gebracht werden mit hilfe
des internationalen roten kreuzes und
werden dann in deutschland verteilt mit
einer mechanik die der kleeblatt
funktion war den kurven entspricht da
wird ein hub gebildet wo die also patio
die verletzten verwunderten dann
ankommen werden dann verteilt über die
bundesländer und da arbeiten wir sehr
eng zusammen wie gesagt mit dem
internationalen roten kreuz für die
verbringung nach deutschland und der
bundeswehr was die kleeblatt also in
funktion angeht zum dritten haben wir
also eine möglichkeit diejenigen die als
geflüchtete nach deutschland kommen mit
leistungen nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
zu versorgen das
wird hier herangezogen für stationäre
wie aber auch für ambulante leistungen
enthält nicht den kompletten katalog der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherung wollen
aber hier also den pflichten den
geflüchteten
entgegenkommen dem wir zum einen also
hier die abwicklung der genehmigung und
der bezahlung über die krankenkassen
also etwas in einigen bundesländern
schon gemacht wird zur regel machen
wollen und ich werde auch durch eine
klarstellende
durch eine klarstellung zusammen mit dem
bundesinnenministerium mit fräse werde
ich also die kommunen bitten bei der
genehmigung der leistungen die also hier
benötigt werden für die registrierten
flüchtenden dass der leistungskatalog
der gkv auch abgebildet wird alle
bewerber leistungsgesetz ist der
leistungskatalog eingeschenkt im
vergleich zur gkv und ich werde hier
darum bitten was beim
genehmigungsverfahren war es ja beim
kommunen liegt dass man dort so
genehmigt als wäre es der
leistungskatalog der gkv hier wollen wir
eine unbürokratische schnelle regelung
machen da bin ich in der vorbereitung
der abfassung in diesen stunden und zum
vierten es ist auch so dass aus
deutschland
pflegekräfte aber auch ärztinnen und
ärzte in der ukraine arbeiten wollen das
also dafür möchte ich mich ausdrücklich
bedanken das ist ein heldenhafter
einsatz den niemand von uns
unterschätzen kann bei der jetzigen
gefahr somit dazu kann man niemanden
auffordern das ginge zu weit aber
diejenigen die es machen wollen das muss
man anerkennen wir wollen daher helfen
mit der bundesärztekammer haben wir
dafür ein portal geschaffen wo man sich
allgemein informieren kann und für
diejenigen die es umsetzen wollen gibt
es dann die möglichkeit über das
auswärtige amt nur mit den
internationalen organisationen die das
dann also ermöglichen also tatsächlich
einen solchen aufenthalt vorzubereiten
da wird auch eine vergütung dann also
ermöglichen und an unserer versicherung
aber wie gesagt das sind die vier
möglichkeiten an denen wir arbeiten
ich möchte ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen
dass deutschland versuchen wird und die
gespräche für die gesamte
bundesregierung
wir wollen wirklich dass deutschland ein
führende rolle bei der medizinischen
versorgung der opfer also der
kriegsopfer aber auch der geflüchteten
menschen aus der ukraine spielen wird
und ich möchte es noch einmal hier auch
arzt also dass nicht nur als minister
sonders
vorurteilen dass also der hasserfüllte
und also
unentschuldbare krieg hier auch so
geführt wird das gezielt medizinische
einrichtungen angegriffen werden das ist
ein tiefpunkt kriegsführung ein
absoluter tiefpunkt der rezession auf
denen wir durch kampfmaßnahmen wieder
eingreifen wollen noch können aber wir
werden zumindest alles tun was wir
können um flüchtlinge und so versehrte
verwundete hier in deutschland so gut
wie wir das können zu behandeln
medizinisch zu behandeln
damit sind wir einfach aus zeitlichen
gründen am ende dieser veranstaltung
angelangt ich bitte um verständnis für
die wenigen online fragen nach fragen
die noch unbeantwortet blieben danke
unseren gästen sehr herzlich fürs kommen
und sagen dass es hier um halb zwölf mit
der regierungspressekonferenz weiter
geht es erst mal